[Music]
seriously this time will it be the most
dramatic ending ever there are rumors
about how re Lyon Dec junior season of
The Bachelor will play out with host
Chris Harrison promising major moments
ET spoke to the women at the shows women
tell all taping they know what went down
and have strong feelings about it I'm
just mad at the way that he handled
things and I'll let you guys decide for
yourselves how old fans react to it he
followed his heart and he went with his
gut I just wish he had taken a moment to
breathe and to reflect I just don't
agree with the way that he handled
things and I think that I'm just I'm
heartbroken and other people are also
like coming home I thought that he would
have a very hard time making a choice so
I thought was my I told my mom I was I
think he's gonna have a really hard time
making a choice so I'm not that
surprised how do you think people will
view re when this is all over I think it
just definitely depends on their
perspective and what they think of the
different women that he still has on the
show right now I myself was a bit
disappointed but I mean it's appointed
in re yeah a little bit disappointed in
re but in the end you know the heart
wants what it wants and I think that
he's justified whatever decision he's
gonna make for himself
stay tuned people The Bachelor airs
Monday nights on ABC
[Music]